okay let's go back to
um to a
uh five minute game apparently
now i'm playing um
according to my opponents
avatar i'm playing albert einstein
which is um obviously an interesting
interesting sort of challenge for me
just one sec
i need to start eating before i play
rather than during
okay anyway we have a
khan this is in here
if i do play g6 all my p pawns would be
on
on light squares um but
the idea is to while you're waiting
a little bit with the development you
you are staying flexible um the knight
from v8 can go to c6 or d7 and also the
knight
from g8 can go to either f6 or e7
and a3 is is decent but it's
it's obviously a little bit slow
and um yeah queen c7 is very typical in
order to play
in order to play knight f6 without
allowing
um e5
okay so this is interesting [ __ ] f4
first of all
e5 does not win a piece because of
bishop g3
uh keeping the pin on the queen
secondly after d6
well sacrifices
with bishop b5
followed by knight b5 is already
somewhat looming after long castles for
instance i probably would have gone
e5 then and if bishop b5 ab5
knight b5 go [ __ ] queen c6 bishop g5
97 looks a bit dangerous but maybe i
um maybe i would have been fine there
bishop g5
violates one of the
[Music]
one of the main rules of opening play
that you should not
you should not move the same piece twice
and also it sort of helps me
develop since i wanted to go 97 anyway
also i could have gotten bishop e7 which
would also have helped me with
development and now i think he's a
little bit
a little bit stuck yes his position is
nice
pieces are well developed but the
question is
where are you actually going to attack
and meanwhile i will castle next
and i will hopefully have a very solid
position with maximum
[Music]
flexibility
and taking an f6 is not positionally
uh desirable usually you should not
exchange bishops for
for nights without some concrete
justification
but then again i'm sure
sure a lot of you already know that
again in the theme of staying flexible
i'm as you do in many of these
positions i'm placing the rook opposite
his queen
which can be very useful um in case the
position is opened and e5
i guess is reasonable
but i think concretely it does lose a
pawn
since obviously ba3 the knight on c3 is
hanging
and most probably i will be upon up with
um with a better
position as well um and knight f3
um yeah i don't know what that move is
all about
now i get to take on on b2
as well attacking both c1 and c3 and the
rook on e5
via x-ray um
and um
he's going to be lucky if he loses just
an exchange probably yeah it's going to
be
going to be a full piece if he'd move
the knight to let's say e2
it would have taken an f3 first and yeah
knight g5 now he's
he's losing the
uh the plot this very often hop um
happens to to low rated players um
that you make a bunch of reasonable
moves
and once you make
one mistake or even even a blunder then
they they very often compound and you
make a whole whole bunch of them and
and your your position collapses